[Music]
today
i am announcing my plans to become your
next mayor of london
[Applause]
oh yes
christmas came early boys i have been
calling this
for over a month now i'll show you proof
right now so you know that i'm not
lying look at this this is me the 17th
of september brian rose is going into
politics in the next 12 months
i'm calling it now i knew it why
because everyone was seeing through his
lies his deception
and people were starting to see who
brian rose actually is he's a grifter
aka he goes back and forth between
different causes never really sticking
with one
just trying to get your money oh yeah
and he's really good at it
he got a million dollars for the digital
freedom platform what has he done with
that
nothing he said he was going to build a
platform instead
he hired out third party software he
said he was going to sue youtube
he hasn't sued youtube he said he was
going to get blockchain technology he
hasn't gotten blockchain technology
instead
he spent your money for what where's
those audited accounts oh
well sorry he's moving on he doesn't
care about your money anymore that he
took from you
instead now he's going on to his next
grift actually
he had a grift before running for mayor
but this is his newest grip which we'll
get into in a second uh but i knew that
he was gonna do this right
because grifter's gotta grift and when
they fail to come through on their
promises they have to move on to the
next thing quickly right
so he was supposed to be the freedom of
speech guy now
he's moved on from that he's lost
patience because his followers no longer
support him
so then he moved on to this new thing it
was a reality show
that he launched in june 23 of 2020
and we want to help you create
that transformation that didn't work so
he's got to move on to the next script
he can't get money from you that way
he's not getting any of your donations
anymore he's got to move on so now he's
running for politics
all of a sudden out of nowhere i see
videos like this how we get
london back to work and i say to myself
oh this fits with nothing brian has done
before
it must be a campaign he must be running
for office and sure enough
i was right now let me say right up
front whether or not
you agree with me whether or not you
want brian rose to win
let me tell you youtubers have a bad
track record with running for
office i'm just going to be honest if
we're talking about his legitimate
odds regardless of my opinion regardless
of your opinion
you know we have a lot we don't have a
huge sample set of youtubers we really
only have a few examples we have people
like carl benjamin who ran for office in
the uk
failed we have people like joey salas
who ran for office in america
failed now you can argue case by case
what mistakes they made in running
but by and large it seems to me that uh
just youtubers deciding that oh yeah i
could just run for office
i don't think they fully understand that
this is not a game you can just jump
into
overnight so my prediction is this
campaign is going to be a total disaster
i think the media is going to eat him
alive his supporters are going to eat
him alive after they realize
he doesn't actually care about free
speech and he doesn't actually care
about
uh censored voices he's going to drop
them like a hot potato as soon as it's
politically convenient and i think his
history of grifting is going to eat him
alive
his history of failing to come through
on his promises and his repeated lies i
think it's gonna catch up with him
uh because he's already asking for more
donations i mean brian i bet you didn't
donate rose
is back baby he wants your email address
and he wants your money
third give us your email address below
as well as a link
on how to volunteer and donate to my
campaign
there it is all right look at that look
there's a little donate button and
everything i wonder
how he figured out how to fundraise like
that i mean honestly dude i think he's
gonna head fake his supporters again
he's gonna be like yeah donate to my
campaign
i'm mr politician now and then in three
weeks he's gonna drop out take the money
and run
i will need the help of every citizen of
this great city working together
towards our common goal i mean in some
ways dude to be completely honest with
you guys
i think brian's biggest advantage if i'm
gonna pay him a compliment
is that politicians are sleazy they're
deceptive
they lie they cheat they steal hey
did i just give the tinder profile of
brian rose so i actually think in some
ways maybe brian rose is the most fit
youtuber to ever go into office and for
that reason he could be a good fit like
in terms of i think he can lie enough i
think he's definitely enough of a snake
so i think he's going to do just fine in
that sense but i also think his ties
with david ike people like that
are going to hurt him and i think he's
going to try to distance himself from
those people
but that it's not going to work and his
followers are going to hate that because
they like brian rose because they think
oh man he actually is one of us when in
reality
he just used david ike for his own means
he's going to throw him away as soon as
he can
i mean but one thing i want to call out
from the very get-go is that
he lies about like why he's running for
office he says he wasn't planning to run
for mayor that but that he couldn't
stand idly by
i had no intention of becoming your next
mayor
i have always been an entrepreneur and a
broadcaster first
i've always been a grifter but then i
realized politics is one of the greatest
grifting games of mankind and that's why
he chose to run for mayor because he's
just scrambling
his business is failing he needs
something to do other than his business
because no one believes in him anymore
i mean if you look at his most recent
crowdfunding campaign
for uh you know his followers his
grifting campaign he's only raised
twenty five hundred dollars of the two
hundred fifty
thousand dollars he needs in this month
and it's already
halfway through the month so people
aren't supporting him anymore he knows
it he needs something to shift to which
is why he's running for office
that's my prediction we will be covering
this i'm fascinated dude
if anything else is going to be super
entertaining and i'm here for it dude
anyway that's it i got it i'll see you
guys next time
i bet you didn't donate for all the
people that donated to the digital
freedom platform
so again we're closing this thing out on
may 3rd someone need your money
donate to my campaign i need to love
your money
donate to my campaign
[Music]
putting it to serious use here you might
say i'm crazy
but i say donate to my campaign
i bet they didn't donate
but they didn't donate today i'm
announcing my plans
to become your next mayor of london let
me guess
you didn't donate